before we start the show this is a very
sad thing that i want to talk about and
i didn't i didn't think i would ever
have to do this and this is a tragedy a
unique
human
tragedy
and many of you
don't know this because this information
is being kept from you you're being lied
to
and i have a pretty good idea of who's
doing it
but
i must
i must come clean
about what i know
this is true
i can't
sleep at night
perpetuating a fraud
and that we know both of us know
is not true
joe rogan
passed away from the coronavirus last
week
um
it killed him almost instantly
it was
very tragic
he had 17 strokes
an hour after testing positive
it was incredibly sad
not only did it kill him
but
it was so
shocking
that young jamie
the producer of the joe rogan experience
okay
lost his mind
after joe was
after joe died of the
covet young jamie went nuts
he went completely insane
and no one knows where he is right now
okay
this is something that is being kept
from you
by spotify
and
on it
the real illuminati
the supplement companies are keeping
this from you joe died
even though
he was taking all of the supplements
vitamin d
cresceratin
magnesium
all of them
he died instantly
he lost his mind before he died as well
he was not making any sense he was
he was in a chair
and his last words i swear to god
and this is sad
yeah it is very sad are we more relevant
in the podcast base now probably yeah
but this is very sad
his last words he was just screaming
ivermectin
as he was stroking out in a chair
i remember
it so
it's not right and it's sad
um but we have a uh
a memorium what do you call it an in
memoriam yeah like they play at the
oscars that's right
of of joe
that young jamie tried to move into his
house
and he walked in and he looked at joe's
wife and he said i'm the king now and
she shot him
so
this is what's going on in texas
so let's play the memorium here for
the man that's more responsible for our
career than any other really other than
me
but
it's sad it's sad it is not it is
unfortunate that this happened
and it is very sad the way young jamie
has handled this trying to steal joe's
wife and move into his house
it's crazy
it's completely absurd that this
behavior
i mean so let's take a look at this uh
montage here
[Music]
it's a tough way to go
[Music]
he was fat
that's part of what people don't know he
smoked too his
every time he did that show he was in a
corset
his real size
would would i mean it would stun people
it was stunning